We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P we
talked earlier about the new book, a warning
written by an anonymous Trump staffer.
Here is speculation about who that staffer
might be.
Hey David, this is day from California.
Yes.
Do you know that book written by that author
called anonymous rumor has it the offers,
Kelly Conway.
Can you confirm or deny that rumor?
Right.
I cannot confirm or deny, but the, you know
the interesting, I've heard that speculation
as well and I think part of it is it's widely
known that Kellyanne Conway is husband.
George Conway is a major critic of the president
of the United States.
Donald Trump.
How could it be that Kellyanne Conway is such
a Brown nosing Trump advisor and she's married
to a guy who is so publicly an antagonizer,
an antagonist of Donald Trump.
And one of the speculations is that behind
the scenes, Kellyanne Conway is disgusted
with Donald Trump, much like her husband and
that she is the anonymous person who wrote
the letter in the New York times, the op ed
in the New York times last year and that she
is the author of the book about the Trump
white house.
I have no idea.
Uh, certainly you can frame up a scenario
where it seems logical, but I don't know anything
else about it.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the resignation of the
Bolivian president [inaudible].
We will also talk about why people are left
or right handed and whether that is changing
over time.
I am a lefty myself politically and in the
literal sense.
And also I had a really weird ghost text message
that a friend of mine received from me a few
days ago, and we have figured out what it
is that caused it.
And apparently this confused thousands of
[inaudible]
people.
All of these stories and more on the bonus.
Joe, get instant access by becoming a member@joinpacmandotcomorbybecomingapatronatpatrion.com
slash David [inaudible], the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].